Film Courage: Clifton, when you first started
acting and booking roles, what was your vision
for your career?
Clifton Collins, Jr.: Vision for my acting
career?
Gosh, I think when you’re younger…I don’t
know if we always know the real reasons why
we get into a business.
Sometimes it’s in hindsight that you realize
“Oh, these were the steps that led me up
to this?”
I don’t know that I had one?
I know that I wanted to do roles that mattered.
I wanted to represent communities of people
that didn’t have voices, I knew that going
in.
It’s kind of interesting insight to have
when I was 17.
Film Courage: You grew up around the business,
didn’t you?
Your grandfather was in the business?
Clifton: I’m a fourth generation entertainer
so my Grandfather, my Great-Grandfather, my
Great-Grandmother.
My Grandfather was a contract player for John
Wayne, he did a lot of Westerns.
Film Courage: So when you told your family
that you wanted to be an entertainer, did
they say…well there is also a downside to
it?
Were they always positive about it or were
they cautious?
Clifton: My Grandfather was the only positive
voice.
He was the only “You can do it” that I
got.
My Mom was not for my career, many friends
weren’t.
It’s a tough business.
But my Grandfather was like “No, you can
do it.
I know you can do it.”
And I just needed to hear it, I just needed
someone to believe in me.
And that was the one voice.
Film Courage: Did you do a lot of imitations
growing up?
Because you’re like a chameleon-like style,
you can be so many different characters.
Did you do imitate a lot of people growing
up, teachers, etc.?
Clifton: I did, that’s really intuitive
of you.
I did.
I got in a lot of trouble in high school because
of it.
I got laughs, I did…because Grandpa…you
think of a movie like RIO BRAVO with Dean
Martin and Walter Brennan and all these unique
different voices, it was just fun to imitate.
We started tap dancing when we were seven
so sometimes just to pass the time as a kid
I’d do voices.
Me and my cousin, I mean you hate it…when
you’re tap dancing when you’re seven,
you just don’t like it.
Today, I love it.
Film Courage: What do you consider as your
first success as an actor?
Clifton: First success, gosh?
Honestly, I think there’s a danger in saying
a first success because I think life is a
series of successes and failures.
So even in this business success to me is
doing the job that I got to do in that room,
whether I get the role or not but the fact
that I’m able to pull off a performance
and give a performance because I like to give
a performance when I audition instead of auditioning.
You know that kind of like to do a lot of
the prep work prior, like some of the heavier
prep work that most actors reserve for after
you get the gig.
If I have the time, I’ll delve completely
into it, it’s just part of the fun if you
want to do a good job.
But in regards to making a living, it’s
a struggle.
You’re juggling jobs, you’re juggling
regular jobs that let you go to auditions
on top of auditioning.
So there’s a struggle and success in that
as well.
I’d say in terms of benchmarks in my career
like the first gig that you get where you
get to be SAG, you get your SAG card you’re
like “Wow!
I finally got my SAG card.”
And that was my first commercial so that was
fun.
So then you look at a film like maybe 187
which was probably one of the greater challenges
in my early career.
There was so much to learn, the mentorship
I got from Sam Jackson was just kind of set
the pace for me in a lot of different ways.
In the ways that he acted and how he prepped
even deeper, harder and longer.
I was like “Oh my God.
I’ve got to do this.”
Because I want to be that good watching Sam
do his thing and I was just “My God?”
So he set the bar pretty high for me so that
was fun.
But I think my first really big role to be
challenged by somebody of Sam’s caliber
and to rise up to that occasion, that was
fun.
Film Courage: I know with a lot of things
in this town you can go to one level and you
think “Oh, it’s just going to keep being
like this.”
It’s going to be this upward staircase and
sometimes you realize you’re back to square
one.
Clifton: Sure.
Film Courage: In any endeavor out here.
Clifton: Sure, I’m very familiar with square
one.
Film Courage: So am I.
How do you deal with that square one point?
Clifton: You just love it.
Film Courage: You do?
Clifton: You have to.
You’ve got to love the process.
You’ve got to be okay with square one.
It’s always a struggle I think.
Different forms of challenges reinvent themselves,
obstacles, you try to develop a foresight
to see those things coming.
But to get back to square one, you embrace
it and you work diligently and extra hard
to get ahead in your craft and auditions or
whatever it is that you’re doing, writing,
directing.
Film Courage: So who is your character Nathan
in A CROOKED SOMEBODY?
Clifton: Nathan is a troubled soul who has
been dealing with his past and as a result
he is struggling with atonement.
He wants to atone I think he just doesn’t
know how.
Yeah, that’s a difficult question.
Film Courage: Do you think people can change?
Sorry to jump in but…
Clifton: No, please.
Film Courage: Do you think people really can
change?
Clifton: I do believe that people can change
but also you’ve got to go past square one.
You’ve got to get knocked down and be humbled,
like truly, truly your soul’s got to be
humbled.
And I think only then will real change happen.
I don’t think…it’s just amazing in these
times as we look at our society, I find it
troubling that people have to get knocked
down to have any sense of empathy or compassion
for others.
It’s like “Why do you have to be down
and out to care about people.”
You know what I mean?
So Nathan is already down and out, I think
he’s probably been down and out for quite
some time.
That beats you down when you don’t address
whether it’s a psychical ailment, emotional,
mental, things like that they are going to
turn into something else that’s not positive
but continue to grow and attempt to manage
it as best as you can and survive.
It didn’t really try to find out what Nathan
used to do but I tried to reverse engineer
so much stuff so he still lives in a trailer
in an abandoned area so he’s surviving barely.
Film Courage: He might be protecting himself,
too.
Clifton: Could be, there’s a lot of different
things happening.
But certainly I wanted to be able to demonstrate
that darkness is in all of us and it’s up
to us to act on it and I wanted to be able
to show that he’s quite capable of being
that bad person.
It’s really about him being in control of
his emotions and a desire to really change.
I don’t know…I think we slide the scales
of justice, which isn’t really justice when
you slide them and you make excuses for certain
things that you do.
You can look at the good that you do and go
“Oh, I’ve done these good things.”
But I’ll turn a blind eye to these bad things
that I do occasionally.
You’re either bad or you’re good.
Film Courage: Yes and without giving away
too much of the story and as Trevor (The Producer/Director
of A CROOKED SOMEBODY) these character arcs
you can also see what seems good, it’s an
interesting look at perception (we’ll just
keep it at that) and looking deeper at someone’s
intentions which is something that we’re
exposed to every day on Twitter without going
too far into it.
Clifton: On my God.
Film Courage: How often would you say you’re
handed an acting role?
Clifton: Like get offers?
Film Courage: Yes, where someone is like “This
is a role we know we want you to play.”
Versus you have to go in and audition, you
have to play the game versus someone saying
we know we want you specifically.
Clifton: Well you don’t want to do every
offer that you get.
So…how often?
It’s kind of cyclical.
I think it kind of depends what’s out, what’s
popular.
I’ve got so much work behind me there is
no telling who has seen what.
So it goes in waves, I think in the last few
years this was certainly one of them [Clifton’s
role of Nathan in A CROOKED SOMEBODY].
But when I read the script I was like “Oh
my God I really want to play this role.
This is amazing.”
I guess we found each other, you know what
I mean?
And I loved working with Trevor and Rich of
course and it was just great.
The collaboration was really fantastic, so
it was a good time.
And these kind of Indies are special.
They’re open to suggestions and ideas based
off of some of the research that I’d done.
But to answer your question thought I probably
get an offer or a couple offers a month.
Film Courage: So it that what determines it
for you because I thought with Nathan you
really owned his this person, you inhabited
this person’s skin.
Is that why you might turn something down
is that you feel I don’t know if I can own
it?
I don’t know if I can respect it?
Clifton: Well I think I definitely appreciate
a challenge, a challenge as an artist.
I like to be challenged to do things that
I haven’t done before so I get to learn
a new skill set or I get to jump into another
culture, another lifestyle.
There’s only a handful of roles that I won’t
really play like pedophiles.
The one they called me about THE LOVELY BONES,
I was like “I heard about this book.
It’s an amazing book from what I understand.
And “Yeah, we want to meet with you about
this role.”
“It’s about” “Well it’s not really
about a little girl and?”
“Well you don’t really him do things.”
“It doesn’t matter.”
I don’t want to be the image of someone
who says “Wow, that’s what I do.”
Or “That’s how I feel.”
I just can’t, I can’t.
The research on that is taxing on the soul.
I’m very ani-that…so.
So I passed on it.
I said “Hey let Stanley Tucci get it and
get a nomination and that was before his name
was even in the mix.
And if I’m not mistaken I think Stanley
did do it and get a nomination.
I don’t know.
I’d be ashamed personally.
But that’s just me, you know?
Film Courage: Sure.
If you were do give someone a five minute
acting lesson, what would it be a couple things?
Clifton: Five minute acting lesson?
Gosh I guess it depends on the material because
you can’t teach everything, especially the
stuff that you learn in 30 years.
So I’d rather give you what you need for
this audition than what you will carry throughout
your career.
Hopefully with those little lessons will be
someone creative anchor to keep in your back
pocket which is always sweet.
I’ve ran into a few older…older than when
I worked with them kids that reached out to
me recently and thanked them for the acting
lessons that I taught them and the mentorships.
Film Courage: So we know that being on set
is not just acting, it’s navigating personalities
and politics and hierarchies.
How do you earn the respect of a fellow actor?
Clifton: Do the work, do the work, do the
work.
And it’s funny because you’ll do certain
projects with an Ed Harris and then on this
film [A CROOKED SOMEBODY] but I already won
Ed’s respect with this film and on WESTWORLD.
And so I called a few friends that had worked
with him to find out a little background on
him.
And I studied really hard to learn my lines,
I studied really hard to learn his lines just
in case he says “What’s my line?”
And I could be like “I think you say….maybe?”
You never know how someone is going to take
it.
You have to navigate.
So I navigate and he goes “Oh?
Thanks partner.”
So I did that and then I slammed the scene
where my wife goes and then he came running
over to me pointing at me and he was like
“Yes!
Yes!
Yes!”
Pointing and frothing and he frickin’ kicks
me in my shin real hard and he goes “That’s
how you do it!”
And then when he walked away I go “I hope
that’s going to leave a mark.
Look what Ed Harris did to me because I did
a good job!”
It’s pretty rad.
It’s pretty awesome.
So that’s how I got his respect.
Film Courage: But I’m sure…like you said
you have to navigate.
Clifton: You’ve got to navigate, Sam Jackson
I was dying to get his respect.
He’s definitely a great mentor only second
to my grandfather.
But this man knows everybody’s, he knows
everybody’s lines.
He knows when the camera moved and on what
line and where he did what.
He knows everything.
It’s really amazing.
So in rehearsals…he was teaching me a lessons,
we’ve had this conversation before, he’s
got these monologues at the end of the film
that are actually much bigger than what ended
up in the film.
And in rehearsals Kevin Reynolds is like “Hey,
you guys ready to do this scene?”
And Sam looks up and says “Yeah, man, let’s
do it?”
And he throws the scenes on the floor.
Sam threw them out and he doesn’t need them
(he’s got the big speeches anyway).
So then I’m holding my gun and he looks
up at me with tears (he can get tears from
this eye and this eye by the way.
He can make this cry right now, he can hold
them, I can’t do that.
But he can so when I saw him holding the tears
he literally put the pedal to the medal.
And I thought “Oh, my God.
I don’t know if I can ever be that good?”
So I just remember racing home and delving
as deeply as I could just to get any respect
from him.
He’s a tough love kind of guy, so you’ve
got to really, really earn it.
Film Courage: Some times those kind of people
are easier to trust.
In an industry where…you want to be professional
but tough love people are easier to trust
because you know where they’re coming from.
Clifton: I talk to him quite often…I honestly
really didn’t know, I think this came…I
lost my father, I was at my father’s funeral
two days before the climax of the movie, we
shot the movie in sequence so I was really
emotional…It was a rather suicidal-type
of scenario.
We’d done the rehearsal and they asked me
if I minded doing my coverage first instead
of Samuel because I was obviously dealing
with some heavy life issues.
They all supported me tremendously and I think
it was then that I had the courage to ask
“Well, what’s Sam think about the work
I’m doing anyway?”
“Sure they can do coverage on me first,
I’m fine with that.
Is Sam cool with that?
Is that what Sam wants?
Because I’ll do whatever Sam wants.”
And they were like “Yeah, he’s totally
fine with it.”
Because that’s when I asked them because
Samuel himself didn’t tell me, he was holding
it close to the chest.
He’s really dope, I mean I love him so…
Film Courage: It’s interesting because sometimes
you’re at a point where certain things are
going on and if everything falls apart, it’s
okay (we were having this conversation driving
over here and I’m stealing your words) but
as long as you’re staying true to yourself
and some amazing things can happen because
you’re at this point where you’re not
really about pleasing somebody, you’re all
about doing what’s right in the moment and
sometimes some really amazing things can happen.
Clifton: That’s a good way to live.
Because as true as we think we’re being
with ourselves we can always be a little truer,
seeking a depth of authenticity if you will.
I’ve just been on this crazy journey lately
of my work and the demands of trying to do
better work has pushed me to lose sleep and
study harder and faster and just go longer
and so it’s interesting because if you pay
attention to the signs in those moments and
do what’s right and what speaks to your
integrity, I can always rest well with whatever
happens.
I’m not feeling bad, I’m feeling good
about the decisions that I make and that’s
a good feeling.
Film Courage: What movie made you want to
be an actor?
Clifton: I can’t really say it was a movie.
It was actually a series of…you go to college
and they’re like “Oh, you’ve got to
select what you’re going to do for the rest
of your life.”
And I’m like “At 18?
I can’t even buy alcohol.
You want me to make a life decision?”
You know what I mean?
So it’s just such a weird thing.
I went to a college prep high school so a
lot of these guys were going to Ivy League
colleges afterwards.
I figured out toward the end of high school
that I didn’t want to do that, that I wanted
to be an actor.
And during this moment of wondering should
I do it?
I was teaching martial arts at the time to
children and I had a moment where I just had
a series of adults and children ask me if
I was an actor, or that I reminded them of
this actor or this character, all within like
six to eight week span.
I’d have people with me when it would be
happening, it was just happening so frequently
and it was like “Alright, maybe I should
listen to the voices of these people that
I don’t know.
And I asked my grandfather, Mom wasn’t into
it, she’s like “You’re not going to
make it.
No way in hell.”
She actually laughed at me.
Which sucks as a kid.
You turn to your parents as mentors and teachers
and this and that but that’s a whole other
story.
Grandpa said yes.
So I’m grateful for that.
When he said “You can do it."
That’s all I needed to hear just from somebody
I cared about who I knew cared about me telling
me something like that.”
You know throughout your career you’re going
to have hundreds of thousands of doubts (even
while working).
I spoke to Jack Lemmon on a film that I was
doing…that he was doing and I happened to
be working with him is what really happened.
And I asked him…I mean he’s a legend I
knew that then when I was in my 20’s working
with him.
And I asked him how he dealt with challenges
back in his day.
Grandpa was a contract player, so he had worked
every week whether he was getting paid.
And he was like “Oh, my God, Clifton, I
thought every week was my last gig.
It’s Jack Lemmon!”
You thought every gig was your last?
So I’m okay.
I’m okay when I get really scared or I think
I’m not going to make it, I’ve got my
bills paid for the most part, you know I’m
good.
I don’t live in a mansion but I don’t
want a mansion.
I don’t need a mansion, not to be happy.
Film Courage: Problems of prosperity.
What do you want people to take from your
character Nathan [in A CROOKED SOMEBODY]?
Clifton: I don’t know…people being more
open-minded to things, questioning things,
being moved by the film in some way, shape
or form that makes them a better person, hopefully?
I don’t know, hopefully it’s entertaining?
Film Courage: It is.
Clifton: Just be entertained.
I think everything else will follow.
It’s a fun one.
Film Courage: Yes and there’s an interesting
ending.
I don’t want to spoil it.
Clifton: So many moments in that film so interesting.
It’s a fun one.
I’m happy with this one.
I’m really happy.
I’m a tough critic, especially of my own
stuff.
I’d be the first to tell you to not see
it let me put it that way.
I’ve had friends who are like “Hey, we’re
going to go watch you.
We want to support you.”
I’m like “No, you go see it because you
want to see the movie, don’t go to support
me because I don’t want to take the blame,”
This is a good one.
I won’t be taking any blame, it’s a good
one.